a mother
and child forced to take refuge in a
school
just one of several azerbaijani families
who fled here from nearby villages
they're escaping heavy fighting near the
border of nagorno-karabakh
that's torn their lives apart
as we have children we were forced to
come here but we go back and
forth even if they destroy our house we
will go back
over the border in the disputed region
of nagorno-karabakh
this armenian father surveys the
wreckage
his two sons have been fighting to
protect this breakaway territory
he blames azerbaijan for the devastation
15 to 20 times a day we can't leave
basements
or shops are closed there's nothing to
eat
[Music]
it's controlled by ethnic armenian
forces
the last two weeks have seen the worst
fighting since a war over the disputed
territory
ended in 1994. russia has been mediating
between these two former soviet states
in the early hours of saturday morning a
ceasefire was announced
the republic of azerbaijan and the
republic of armenia
are starting substantive negotiations
with the aim of achieving a peaceful
settlement
as soon as possible now there's to be an
exchange of prisoners and the
repatriation of bodies
but for families like these caught up in
this conflict
their biggest dream is for a lasting
peace
now let's bring in lawrence brewers the
caucasus program
director at the london-based peace
building organization conciliation
resources
mr brewers thanks for joining me so it
sounds like the ceasefire has been
broken before it even got a chance to go
into effect with both sides accusing
each other of launching attacks does
this mean we're back to square one
yes uh as you said the ceasefire is
supposed to have been in place for two
hours now and there are reports that
fighting has continued
um i think there are a number of factors
here first of all
russia doesn't have the same leverage
that it had four years ago the last time
there was a major escalation at that
time russia brokered a ceasefire after
four days and it held
we're now 13 days in and the ceasefire
is not holding
azerbaijan i think is very concerned
about agreeing to a ceasefire and just
seeing
a refreeze without real movement uh on
on the substance of the talks and i
think there's also a paradox
of imminent peace talks each side may
feel that now is the time to
uh make advances to strengthen
negotiating positions before
real talks resume the azerbaijani
president has said that this
would be armenia's quote last chance to
settle
the conflict peacefully this has been
going on for decades why is it proving
so complicated to solve this dispute
well there's a whole range of different
factors but i think the key issue
is that the sides have diametrically
opposed uh positions
on the status of nagorno-karabakh itself
now
the uh the statement released by the
ministry of foreign affairs of russia
underlines that substantive talks should
take place according to the basic
principles
this is a reference to the peace
proposal that's been on the table
since 2007 and the fact that it's been
on the table for so long indicates that
there
is agreement on a number of background
of less pressing secondary issues but
the status of nagorno-karabakh
is the key sticking point and we also
need more
security the armenian side has been
calling for increased ceasefire
monitoring infrastructure
uh while the azerbaijani side has been
calling for for more politics and more
uh movement on the political issues at
stake and i think this is the dilemma
that the mediators face russia and
turkey have been heavily meddling in
this conflict
walk us through what's at stake here for
them
well i think this new conflict uh is
indicative
of uh broader global movements away from
a unipolar multilateral liberal
uh international order to a more
regionalized one
and there is the prospect uh that russia
and turkey
may become you know the key players as
they as they have done
in syria and libya supporting different
factions on the ground so
this hasn't been to date a proxy
conflict but there is a risk
uh that that that that may happen and so
i think that the choice for russia
essentially is whether to agree
to a kind of duopoly with turkey to
manage this conflict
or to remain embedded within a
multilateral framework
of the mints group together with the
united states and france
lawrence brewers thanks for your
analysis
thank you
you